the frontal lobe is tied into emotion
and inhibition and things like that so
when somebody one of your buddies has
too many beers and he's naked on the
table with a lampshade on that's frontal
insert Valor inhibition they they lose
those inhibitory systems so they start
thinking yeah this is a good idea hold
my beer kind of thing so so we want to
do stuff to make those inhibitory
systems stronger and so that that you
know your whole brain is a gas breaking
elge you have to have a ghost system but
you have to have a stop system so we'll
do exercises like anti-stick odds and go
no-go like Simon says stuff and things
like that to activate those Pathways
because anything you do repetitively in
the brain like learning a new golf swing
that will ultimately start to create new
Pathways and then over time when you've
reinforced it enough that's your new
normal that's the beauty about brain
plasticity as long as you're living and
breathing you can you can be 85 years
old and get your brain function working
better so it's a beautiful thing that we
have going for us on that front you
could always rehab the brain